on va commencer avec les footballeurs
boehner a fait des salaires pharaoniques
vous a fait un petit récap on en parle
juste après
si vous avez du mal à finir vos fins de
mois il y en a pour qui le problème ne
se pose pas l'élan
seniors
stars du ballon rond de télé réalité du
petit écran ou même du grand leurs
salaires peuvent parfois atteindre des
sommes astronomiques autour de 3000
euros par mois côté influences et nabila
et son mari thomas vergara qui
décrocherait la première place avec plus
de 350000 euros par mois non ça va très
bien je suis très heureuse aux côtés des
footballeurs les sommes sont nettement
plus importantes 41 millions d'euros par
an pour messi 40 millions par an pour
neymar et bientôt 100 millions par an
pour quillanais mbappé sans compter les
sponsors c'est symbolique enfin pour les
animateurs les salaires varient beaucoup
tout dépend de l'audience de l'émission
et de la chaîne de diffusion pour
exemple jean-pierre pour comprendre et
35000 euros pour une émission miss
france exceptionnelle il conseille à gaz
27000 euros par émission the void rays
quant à benjamin castadi le salaire
serait tenue garder bien secret alors
selon vous les stars sont-elles trop
payés
[Applaudissements]
mich alors on vous laisse oui centre au
pays alors je trouve que répondre non
comme ça c'est voilà c'est facile elles
sont trop payés pas tout faudrait
prendre des cas particuliers mais
globalement moi ce qui me gêne c'est la
différence entre les très très hauts
salaires que les gens ne vole pas et les
bas salaires et ça c'est insupportable
donc elles sont trop payés parce qu'il
ya des gens qui ne sont pas assez payés
je suis pas d'accord qu'une infirmière
gagne si peu qu'un problème si peu que
le smic cela si bas c'est donc c'est une
évidence mais c'est pas tellement le
débat on perd on sait bien qu'une
infirmière malheureusement est pas
atterrir sur un oui très bien qu'un
footballeur par rapport à ce qui va
rapporter mais ils sont trop payés je
réponds oui par rapport aux bas salaires
c'est le différentiel qui me choque mais
voilà vous comparer l'incomparable
excusez moi je les prends votre question
à nos voisins sur la question et dit
comprendre il s'en est maladroit il n'a
jamais rechigné côtoient elle mérite
beaucoup plus surtout les infirmières
mais quand on regarde les bas salaires
bd cela même me blesse c'est que les 100
[Musique]
millions c'est qui va rapporter 300 les
mecs qui rapporte de l'argent ne sais
pas qui se retrouvaient ils font tous
voulaient une à nu c'est fait je veux
dire quand quelqu'un a dit c'est qui
rapporte 40 alors après on peut dire les
10 c'est pas assez je suis d'accord mais
a pas de trop payer ou pas si on peut en
conséquence de ce qu'on rapporte
logiquement c'est ça alors 96 % des
français pensent que des footballeurs
sont trop payés bien sûr mais en même
temps c 17 qui gêne le moins les
français antoine enfin je sais pas où on
a un tableau là pour le pont les
salaires des sportifs et des
footballeurs bon c'est vrai que c'est
pour certains ça dépasse les 100
millions de riels basket 80 millions
d'actifs s'est tous les sportifs et
franchement c'est un peu plus de cachet
au monde
on est payés ici parce que nous
franchement on est on est on est des on
est on a une chance énorme 8,6 mais
alors on devrait être moins de payer
alors on devrait baisser non
convocation au balo
suis désolé
c'est faux culs de dire ça ici
franchement on a une chance énorme mais
on n'est pas parce qu'il en est
réellement gênant mais je veux dire en
garde même quand même très bien notre
vie par rapport à
moi c'est l'hypocrisie moi quand j'ai
monté mon agence au départ les
influenceurs sa naissance c'est vrai
c'était pas vraiment développer j'ai
rencontré les enfants sur télé réalité
il faisait de la promotion pour des
marques en échange de produits
c'est-à-dire qu'on leur offrait des
pulls etc et c'est comme ça que j'ai eu
cette idée où j'aurais dit va-t-en s'ils
gagnent de l'argent et c'est normal que
toi aussi tu en galets c'est pas normal
que la marque en gagnez pas toi t'es pas
le bouffon de la marque en fait c'est
pour être honnête le problème c'est que
les gens qui gagnent de l'argent france
ne le disent pas ne veulent jamais le
dire ils ne veulent pas assumer en
france et nous faut les vivre ce qu'on
gueule oui mais c'est ça ou c'est là où
ça va passer je pense que les gens ils
ont peut-être besoin d'honnêteté et de
dire que voilà on gagne de l'argent
c'est très bien c'est et fierté moi je
suis en france aujourd'hui serait de
l'argent je paye des impôts soutien je
mets le problème maintenant il ya des
gens qui gagnent de l'argent et c'est
d'ailleurs ce que j'ai rencontrés quand
j'ai monté cette agence c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens de télé où j'en étais
tu peux faire la promo alors oui je suis
d'accord de le faire mais je veux pas le
dire que c'est de la pub pas dire je
suis payé pour ça mais en fait non tu
dois le dire parce que c'est la vérité
et c'est juste cette hypocrisie qui est
gênant c'est pas les sommes qu'on gagne
moi j'aimerais quand même revenir sur ce
que je disais vous avez dit que c'était
pas le débat que j'ai moi 96% des
français trouvent que les footballeurs
sont ont payé pourquoi ils trouvent ça
s'il se réfère mais oui se réfère à leur
salaire et il voit la différence et se
disent c'est génial qu'un mba paix soit
le maître absolu du foot qui n des
millions mais moi qui me crève le matin
qui suis commerçant qui suis
prof qui suit professionnels de la santé
tout ça qui nous gagne rien c'est
injuste c'est par rapport à soi qu'on
descend jamais la question aussi que les
footballeurs qui paye tibi beaucoup
d'argent en france par exemple mba pays
gagne c'est pas 100 millions par an je
crois et c'est le web le club a versé 50
millions à l'état
oui le temps en temps oui mais je ne
sont pas avares fille étrange expérience
bien sûr il ya un équilibre à coup sûr
beaucoup d'argent ne voulons rien on lui
propose mais il n'y a pas de problème
mais c'est le différentiel qui est
insupportable aujourd'hui pour moi voilà
j'entends totalement ce que dit gilles
je rejoins ce que dit gilles moi il ya
encore un autre problème c'est dire que
vous voyez il y avait jean pierre
foucault par exemple dans l'extrait et
jean pierre foucault quand on les
appelle par exemple pour lui donner des
ménages est tous à animer il annonce son
cachet et les gens le disent pardon pour
deux heures il dit non vous me payez 40
ans de carrière en fait je pense que
quand les gens ont une grande carrière
quand les gens beaucoup de talent
effectivement il hérite de gagner
beaucoup d'argent et moi ce qui va plus
me gênait c'est des personnes qui je
pense qu' aujourd'hui gagnent beaucoup
d'argent alors qu'elle ne mérite pas
nécessaire je
vais pas vous donner non mais je pense
qu'il ya aujourd'hui c'est vrai il ya
des jeunes ya des jeunes qui ont passé
grand chose de leur vie qui gagne
beaucoup d'argent et c'est aussi ça
peut-être qui tu peux les rendre
détestable et qui créent ces disparités
et qui créait beaucoup de jalousie sur
les réseaux belle amende énorme c'est ce
que ça rapporte par exemple on regarde
même au cinéma dans le cinéma padam
scarlett johansson une charlize theron
elle gagne 4,5 million par film et à une
autre actrice non non non non
plus beaucoup à l'américaine c'est entre
10 millions et 20 millions de dollars
était sur
les wii ea caprio c'est pas un film à
moins de 20 millions de dollars et à
wisches est par exemple ça veut dire
qu'ils en rapporte et non mais je veux
être acteur
c'est trop tard
et essayer au bac et bol par exemple on
parle tout on parlait de tom cruise
évidemment ils sont mavericks là où il
se fait des couilles en or comme il ya
un pardon d'un sexe en or
c'est normal je veux dire c'est ce qui
rapporte il est numéro 1 du box office
donc tout ça est lié effectivement à ce
que tu rapportes et les footballeur
c'est pareil avec leur contrat et tout
le reste est sûre c'est dans les
politiques rivaux texans mais où
activement bienbienbien pays mélenchon
qui m'a menacé débarré et bien oui il
est taxé d' ailleurs les mandats je sais
pas combien il va sûr et accessible
c'est vraiment pour cent
quatre-vingt-dix pour cent quand on fait
l'état de son patrimoine il a après le
gère aussi près de 2 millions d'euros
après midi son chemin c'est blanc riche
mélenchon oui oui je sais pas là je
voyais qu'il faut être honnête est-ce
que vous pensez que les politiques
seront trop la crise ont mis au pot
question d'un salaire dit joe biden il
prend trente mille euros par mois prédit
dans les lycées mais c'est que dalle
c'est l'homme le plus puissant du monde
vous rendez compte que vous ne verrez
plus claude et si on fait une bombe à
trottinette
dégage mais justement si on va dans
votre raisonnement à 10 ans par rapport
à ce qu'ils font et c'est l'arrêt
l'homme le plus puissant du monde qui
dirige le pays qu'on les aime ou pas
j'ai trente mille balles alors oui ce
qui me semble mais il faut quelqu'un qui
dirige entraîner le monde c'est zéro
alors fait demi tour c'est l'oms alors
oui il était dans ses racines 280 euros
par mois je pense que oui 1280 euros à
la seconde on a versé à ceux à qui la
ville a fait main basse sur tout sur les
stocks les vendeurs de pme restent non
je crois pas qu'ils nient 1000 euros par
mois ils touchent surtout le pétrole
l'or note le président 15000 euros par
mois oui c'est clair mais bon c'est pas
c'est pas
un patron du cac 40 sa peine sa gagne
2,3 à 4,5 millions de
flamands
justin trudeau est le premier canadien à
dire c'est qu'ils affinent c'est pas mal
bon poisson est franchement c met à ce
qu'on lit mais qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est que derrière ces salaires ok ça
c'est le salaire immérité bosse
énormément 7 jours sur 7 tout ce que
vous voulez mais tous toute leur vie
quotidienne
elle est payée par le contribuable
sinon ils n'ont aucune dépense ce qu'ils
émettent ils n'ont pas de charge ces
gens là ouais c'est ça qui choque aussi
quand vous êtes député vous avez
l'indemnité député pin enveloppe de
frais alors certes on va le dire c'est
pour payer les collaborateurs ce qui
gêne sont les à côtés et ça c'est pas
très claires comme quand vous avez été
sénateur vous bénéficiez à vie de
privilégié à la retraite à la santé ça
ça gêne les français il ya une certaine
opacité là dedans quand même de moins en
moins ben oui ils ont fait des règles
effectivement il ya eu des règles il ya
le moindre qu'avant dit oui mais ce
qu'on appelle des fonds secrets oui truc
incroyable ça que chaque mois et y avait
une enveloppe qui sortait datant de la
banque de france en liquide a été donné
au premier ministre et le produisent de
velaro distribuera ses ministres il pas
il ya notamment un cd premier ministre
qui a pris son cas après donc les fonds
secrets peu de temps avant d'être
démissionnée d'un certain raymond barre
et qui avait touché 10 millions d'euros
des millions de francs par donc un vrai
et ils l'ont bloc a disparu
alors les animateurs télé vaste sujet
vaste sujet parce que j'ai déjà dit je
le redis je pense que les sommes
annoncées ou présentées ne sont pas les
miens
alors mieux vaut ne rien dire que dire
des conneries autant dire allez-y
bernard parce que je vais m'énerver mais
là on pas ce que c'est mais non mais
c'est vrai parce qu'autrement ya des
productions on a tous des productions
consent travaille depuis longtemps la
télé moi ça fait trente huit ans j'ai
monté une production évidemment pourquoi
parce que dans ces cas là je fais
rentrer tout l'argent dans ma société
évidemment où j'essaie de vivre un
maximum sur ma société d'ailleurs parce
que moi je me verse un salaire minimum
donc je peux très bien déclaré une somme
qui peut surprendre que je me verse tous
les mois et c'est moi qui décide donc
c'est bidon quand ils disent oui sauf
moi je dis rien sur les salaires je
trouve ça indécent moi je suis d'une
famille très modeste je ne veux pas en
parler je ne dirai pas combien je gagne
en revanche ce que je peux dire c'est
que quand j'entends certains animateurs
télé qui ose dire je gagne 3,4 5000 par
mois macha bon là il faut pas prendre
les gens pour des cons n'ont pu lasser
assez honteux que je t'ai dit c'est
l'hypocrisie
tabou en france aussi et que du coup les
gens le vivent très mal et c'est normal
il ya des gens qui vivent tellement mal
tu vois un mec à la télé tu l'aiment pas
par exemple tu t'es dit se connaît on
gagne ce fric là à faire le con la télé
mais mais ça lui fait alors on dit ce
qu'on a réglé le problème
si tu lis si on en parlait librement
peut-être qu'on dirait justement je vais
essayer de faire pareil pour gagner
autant quand on va dans d'autres pays
c'est bien vu pour pourquoi on dit
justement c'est un connard et gagne de
l'argent c'est ça qui fait chier à la
célébrité c'est il ya plein de choses
qui l'a jamais c'est un système très
très français en amérique les gens sont
fiers d'annoncer bien sûr salaire
ailleurs en france moi quand j'ai
commencé à la télé j'ai annoncé comme un
abruti
tu te prends trois contrôle fiscal ok ça
c'est même pas le sais que mes fans en
disant c'est effectivement pas sentir
les sommes sont considérables sous très
importante mais après ça elle annoncé un
salaire de 3 à 4000 euros sur des armes
à ma bossert alors qu'on sait qu'ils ont
une boîte de prod qui est des marges qui
a des choses derrière vraiment autant ne
rien dire que de dire ça et après à
décharge deux amis producteurs et je le
redis mais comme cyril il fait beau
c'est 200 personnes par mois c'est ça
voilà il ya des maisons démolies et il
faut travailler beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de temps donc c'est une
répartition proportionnelle mais ça peut
pas se résumer un salaire mensuel voilà
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas le
dire et c'est faux ce qu'ils racontent
toutes les gens tous les animateurs
télécom entend droite à gauche révéler
leurs salaires c'est faux et je vous le
dis c'est fou d'avoir alimenté ils
mentent il est 100% ça c'est faux à la
télé réalité alors ça qu'est ce qu'ils
esquissent gars il me
manquait alors c'est vrai que c'est des
réussites rapide très rapide deux trois
ans quatre ans cinq ans pour certains et
on parle de 30 50 100 200 300 mille
euros par mois et on m'a dit à
l'oreillette
que parfois c'était beaucoup plus c'est
que c'est ce qu'on dit alors c'est que
s'ils peuvent ramener aussi beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent à des marques
ils font travailler beaucoup de gens ça
fédère magazine entrevue a porté
beaucoup d'argent en fait tout le monde
travaille pour gagner de l'argent faut
pas être hypocrite faut juste lui dire
la vérité c'est que vous et que et que
oui bien bien évidemment que ça a
rapporté de l'argent ça a fait
développer des entreprises a permis aux
entreprises pendant le coc vide de
pouvoir continuer à travailler parce
qu'il y avait que le e-commerce qui
fonctionnait donc grâce aux influenceurs
ils ont pu bosser alors attention en
télé réalité ça représente un petit
panel c'est à dire que sur je sais pas
moi 500 ou 1000 candidats il ya
peut-être un 10 15 qui gagnent beaucoup
et et tant mieux pour eux et puis c'est
éphémère il y en a peut-être un top 5 où
ça va rester pendant des années il
paraît magali que
la tendance change un peu en ce moment
que c'est un peu moins qu'il ya une
espèce de révolte des marques c'est vrai
ou pas non c'est pas une humble démarque
c'est aussi un choix parce que c'est un
nouveau métier et ce métier là il faut
le professionnaliser quand on a démarré
là dedans on ne savait pas moi par
exemple le drop shipping savais pas ce
que c'était il ya encore trois quatre
ans en arrière donc on a appris de nos
erreurs pour pouvoir faire quelque chose
de plus joli et forcément aujourd'hui
mais on fait aussi nous beaucoup plus de
choix restrictif pour faire du travail
de meilleure qualité un des meilleurs
sites et ne pas faire n'importe quoi
parce que on a appris de nos erreurs
pour être meilleur tu vois ça
en fait en fait vous passer une commande
est en fait la puanteur c'est
l'intermédiaire oui et qu'un autre site
il fait venir le public des programmes
de l express pour un port et il leur
ombre il leur envoie avec une mare
suspense était moyen au début mais oui
mais on connaît en fait au début on
comprenait pas ce qu'en fait on se
doutait pas de toutes les mauvaises
personnes qui pouvait y avoir derrière
donc forcément il ya des dégâts donc
aujourd'hui quand on avance on essaye de
faire les choses proprement et forcément
on dit basse annonça n'ont donc
forcément gagnent moins d'argent parce
qu'on dit non à plein de choses donc
c'est tant mieux parce que c'est
travailler sur le long terme faire du
qualitatif protéger aussi les gens qui
nous suivent et est plus basse a fait un
tri naturel aussi des influenceurs qui
veulent aujourd'hui comprendre que le
travail c'est sur les années à venir et
pas que sur un an pour prendre pour
prendre quoi partout il rêver un peu
allez-y je montrais dame barack de
ronaldo ah oui
un petit et un
ennemi d'avis regarde
à gaza lui l'ia entre
ma chambre est l'une des choses les plus
importantes de ma vie
ici c'est là où je dors est ce que vous
savez c'est important de se tenir
informé haut niveau or
le salon où je regarde la télé les
matches
[Musique]
ici c'est l'endroit où je me repose
d'ouvrir avec mes amis
et ici c'est l'endroit où je joue au
foot veut pas on à laquelle un foot
juste ici les nerfs
non
[Applaudissements]